انا اسمي كارولين ماهر وهكلمك النهارده عن
تحقيق
الاحلام هحكي لكم يعني قصتي في تحقيق
حلمي وده التايتل اللي انا اخترته ا كتير
مننا بيكون عندهم حلم معين بيفضلوا ان هم
بيسعوا ان هم يحققوه بس لما الحلم ده ما
بيتحقق بيحسوا ان الدنيا اتهدت او ان خلاص
كل حاجه وقفت والمفروض ان هم ما يحاولو ان
هم يعملوا اي حاجه تاني النهارده هكلمكم
عن حلمي انا ابتديت العب رياضه من سن صغير
قوي كان عندي ادمان لاي نوع رياضه يعني
دوروا عل في النادي ق شعلقه في اي حته
بعمل اي حاجه فقلي شجعوني قوي على النقطه
دي وابتديت العب بالصدفه تايكوندو
ماتسالونيش ليه وازاي بس ده اللي حصل ا
وكان النادي مسافر بطوله في المانيا فكان
اهلي عايزين ياخد بقى خبره السفر وكده
فسافرت والمفاجاه ان انا جبت مداليا فضه
كانت دي اول مداليه ل في حياتي دي اللي
شجعتني ان انا اكمل ابتديت ان انا كل
بطوله اقعد اكسب واكسب واكسب وابتدى جوايا
حلم كان حلمي ان انا اقف على منصه
الاولمبيات وابقى لابسه ميداليا اوليمبيه
وحاطه عالم مصر على كتفي كنت كل يوم بنام
واحلم بيه مستعده ان انا اضحي اي حاجه في
حياتي يعني عشان اوصل للحلم ده وفعلا
ابتديت ان انا اسع له
التايكوندو يعني لعبه شويه صعبه غير ان هي
مرتبطه بالوزن فمحتاجه ان انا دايما احافظ
على وزن معين فكان من وانا عندي 10 سنين
انا باكل اكل معين بنام في وقت معين بصحى
في وقت معين ما
بتفسح بذاكر وب تمرن وبس
وفعلا وانا عندي تقريبا 11 سنه اختاروني
في حاجه اسمها مشروع البطل الاوليمبي كنت
اول بنت في مصر يختاروها في التايكوندو في
المشروع دوت مشروع اعداد لاولمبياد 2004
تقريبا
وابتديت ان انا كنت بتمرن تقريبا سبع
ساعات في اليوم بتمرن الصبح بتمرن الظهر
بتمرن
بالليل واجلت تقريبا سنه ونص في الدراسه
عشان اوصل للحلم ده وقبل الاولمبياد كنا
في معسكر اربع شهور واكتشفت ان انا مش
هلعب وان هم اختاروا حد تاني انضم المنتخب
بقله شهور قصيره حسيت بقى ان كل حاجه
انتهت خلاص انا حلمي ادمر يعني مش مستاهله
انا بعمل كده في نفسي ليه وقعدت شهرين قرر
ان انا خص انا بطلت قعدت اتكلم بعد كده مع
اهلي لا انا حلمي يستاهل مش عشان اربع
سنين يعني ايه المشكله الحياه مش هتقف هنا
وكملت كملت اني اربع سنين اتمرن عشان اوصل
لحلمي وبعد الاربع سنين كنا في اولمبياد
الجامعات في تايلاند هنرجع مصر في ثلاث
ايام ونسافر عشان نلعب تصفيات الاولمبيات
العالميه في مانشستر ده قبل اولمبياد بجين
2008 بعد ما رجعنا بثلاث ايام كان في
ثلاثه المفروض مسافرين لقيتهم سافروا ما
حدش كلمني اكتشفت ان انا اسمي شطب من
البعثه من غير اي سبب ومن غير ما حد يقول
لي ليه كنت عايزه افهم هو هو انا عملت
حاجه وا ايه اللي حصل ما فيش اي حاجه ما
حدش فاهم اي حاجه ا كان في لعيبه ثانيه
سافرت بس الحظ ما حلفها كان في بعد كده
فرصه في التصفيات الافريقيه اكتشفت ان هم
غيروا الميزان يعني بلعت 49 فهي افوا ب 57
فقلت لا انا هتمرن بقى حديد عشان هلعب في
57 مش مشكله بس ما اهلنا برده ف الفرصه
للمره الثانيه بعد ممان سنين واجلت سنه
تانيه كنت في الدراسه فكان الموضوع صعب
قوي قلت لا يعني خلاص كفايه انا عملت كل
حاجه عندي ومش هقدر اعمل اكتر من كده قعدت
ت اني افكر مع اهلي قلنا لا انا حلمي
يستاهل انا مش هقف هنا انا
هكمل اخر مره بقى وقلت خلاص دي الاخيره
وفعلا رجعت كنت عندي شويه احباط في الاول
بس رجعت اتشجع وساعتها عملوا حاجه اسمها
تصنيف عالمي زي السكواش والتنس يعني كل ما
بتلعب بطولات بتجمع نقاط وبيست عليها
بيبقى لي رانك على مستوى العالم ساعتها
كان الترتيب بتاعي ثالث على مستوى العالم
ورابع فكنت في اعلى حاجه فخلاص انا متاكده
ان انا غالبا ان شاء الله هلعب وكان في
اربع بنات هيختاروا منهم اثنين اكتشفت بقى
في 2011 لقيت الاتحاد بيكلمني الو كارولين
ايوه هو بس في حاجه غريبه شويه قلت لهم اه
فقالوا لي هو فاكره التحليل اتعمل من ست
شهور بتاع المنشطات قت اه العينه بتاعتك
جايه ايجابيه نعم مستحيل يعني انا الرياضه
بالنسبه للالعاب الفرديه او التايكوندو
بالذات ما فيش اي افاده ولا افاده ماديه
ولا افاده معنويه ولا اعلاميه ولا اي حاجه
فا ايه هدفي ان انا اخد منشطات عشان ايه
يعني قالوا لي طب احنا هنشوف الموضوع ده
وما تقلقيش واحنا كاتحاد هنه عندل الموضوع
وفضلنا ان احنا نمشي في الموضوع مافيش اي
ما بسمعش اي حاجه عن الموضوع وانا قلت
الموضوع فندين يعني ما فيهوش اي حاجه ببص
على المفروض ان لما بناخد عين ع بتبقى
عينه يا دم يا عينه بول كانت عينه بول ف
كان في ورقه اخدتها بتقول ان دي رقم عينتي
وان انا حصل تحليل يوم كذا فبرا جع الرقم
لقيت رقم العينه مختلف عن الرقم المبعوث
في الايميل فبعت الاتحاد فبعته الاتحاد
الدولي فبعته اعتذار قت خلاص الموضوع
انتهى واحتفلنا بقى وكنا مبسوطين
ا بعدها باسبوعين بدا المنتخب يعسكر عشان
كان عندنا بطوله لقيت ان انا ما حدش كلمني
في حاجه غلط فكنت واخده موقف شويه فهم
قالت لي طب انا هكلم حد الاتحاد اعيد عليه
ونشوف طيب ايه المشكله في ايه تكلمنا فعلا
عضو من الاتحاد فلو حيتك مش عارفه ولا ايه
دي بنتك موقوفه من شهرين موقوفه سنتين
احنا كل مصر عارفه نعم فكانت صعقه فكان
قدامي حلين ان انا ابطل خالص او ان انا
الاقي لها مخرج بصراحه انا كنت عايزه ابطل
ما كنتش قادره ان انا اكمل الموضوع كان
صعب بس بابا وماما قعدوا يتكلموا معايا
يعني اللي عملتيه بقك 11 سنه بتسعي الحاجه
دي حاجه اهم دي سمعتك ده مجهودك في السنين
اللي فاتت كلها ما ينفعش تقفي دلوقتي نكسب
القضيه وبعدين مش عايزه تكملي ما تكمليش
انت حره بس مش هتقفي دلوقتي فعلا اقتنعت
وان انا مش هينفع اقف
دلوقتي وفعلا قعدنا اخدت اجازه من الشغل
طلعنا بقى القانون الدولي وقعدنا نذاكر
انا وماما وبابا وبعد كده اكتشفنا ان في
حاجه في القانون بتقول لو فات ثلاث اسابيع
عن صدور الحكم انا ما عنديش فرصه ان انا
ارفع قضيه او ادافع عن حقي فالموضوع مقفول
فقلنا لا برض نجرب اسال محاميين لقينا في
محامين في انجلترا ومحامين في امريكا ا
المشكله بس ان اسعار كانت حاجه فلكيه كده
امريكا كانوا ارحم شويه يعني القضيه
بتتراوح من 20 ل 30 الف دولار فكان
الموضوع كان صعب جدا بس هو قال لي المحامي
انه في اعمل القضيه تتقبل لو اثبتنا ان
انت مافيش اي حد بلغك غير من خلال الايميل
الاخير لما عملنا مشكله مع الاتحاد طلبنا
منهم يبعتوا كل الاوراق فكان فات ثلاث
ايام تقريبا فقال لي احنا لازم نمشي بسرعه
عشان نقدر ان احنا نلحق الاجراءات مع
المحكمه الدوليه الرياضيه في سويسرا فقلت
له خلاص يعني احنا نعمل اقصى حاجه ونشوف
ايه اللي هيحصل قال لي اه بس احنا مش
هنقدر نبدا غير لما ناخد فلوس الفلوس كلها
تتحول قلت له اه هنعمل ايه دلوقتي ف ما
كنتش عايزه اهلي بصراحه
يتحملوا المصاريف بتاعه القضيه كفايه قوي
اللي هم عملوه طول حياتي وكل حاجه عملوها
لي فاستل منهم فلوس وخدت سولفه من البنك
وحطيت كل الفلوس اللي معايا في اي حته
والحمد لله في الاخر قدرنا ان احنا نجمع
المبلغ كان ساعتها 2011 فترينا ان احنا
نحول مبلغ خمسه خمسه خمسه وانا قاعده على
اصابي بس يحصل اي حاجه بس في الاخر قدرنا
ان احنا نحول كل المبلغ ونرفع القضيه
القضيه قعدت تقريبا حوالي سبع شهور في
المحكمه اتقبلت القضيه لان الاتحاد المصري
والاتحاد الدولي ماقدروش ان هم يقدموا اي
دليل ان هم بلغوني زي ما هم كانوا بيقولوا
ا والقضيه اتقبلت والمفاجاه ان لما اطلب
تقرير المعمل ا ان احنا المحامي طلبه لو
مش بتقوا من البي بي هي دي العينه
بتاعتي العينه بتكون البول بيتقسم في حاجه
اسمها اي وبي دول بيبقى عباره عن ازازتين
المفروض انهم بيتقفل ما بيتفتحو تاني لازم
العينه تبقى ايدنتكال مستحيل ما يبقو زي
بعض بالظبط لان ده بيبقى نفس الكوبايه
بلاستيك بتدلق جوه ازازتين قزاز وبيتقفل
فتقرير المعمل كان بيقول ان العينه اي وبي
مستحيل يكونوا من نفس الشخص والعينه دي
فيها تلاعب وكانوا بيطالبوا ان يتاخد عينه
انيه من اللاعب دوت ما بيكونش معروف
الاسمي بتبقى ارقام عشان ما يبقاش في اي
تحيز لاي
حد بس الاتحاد الدولي ادام اوردر ان هم
يكملوا وخلاص يعني طلعوا ننتيجه وده اللي
حصل فعلا ان هم طلعوا النتيجه وقرار ان هم
هيوقفوني من غير ما يدوني حقي ان انا
ادافع عن نفسي من غير ما يدوني حق ان
انا يعني اثبت براءتي من غير ما يدوني حق
ان انا افتح حتى العينه رقم بي لان لو
الاثنين طلعوا غير متناسقين معناها ان
العينه دي غلط
اوتوماتيك بس وبعد كده كنت مسافر بقى تحدد
معاد جلسه القضيه وانا رايحه الطريق في
المطار كلمني المحامي قال لي الاتحاد
الدولي انسحب وانت كسبتي القضيه ضد
الاتحاد وكنت اول واحده تكسب قضيه ضد
الاتحاد الدولي للتايكوندو
وبعد كده قلت له بقى انا عايزه فلوسي انا
ماليش دعوه انا صارفه مبلغ عايزاه فقال لي
هو بصراحه ا اكبر مبلغ اتحكم فيه في
العالم كان 10000 دولار في اقصى قضيه
قلتله طب نعمل ايه قاللي خلينا نقدم ونشوف
ايه اللي هيحصل المهم ان احنا قدمنا كل
المصاريف كانت تقريبا حوالي يعني 21 22
الف
دولار 2012 اكتشفت ان هم حكموا بان يتصرف
200 الف دولار وده كان اكبر مبلغ على
مستوى العالم يدفع لمصاريف قضيه وطبعا كتب
على القضيه كتير يعني اكتر بره مصر ان هي
اكتر قضيه كان حصل
فيها كبشن او تلاعب على مستوى العالم
ا بعد كده كان المفروض فاضل بقى ست شهور
على الاولمبياد فقلت انا هموت نفسي انا كل
الفتره دي كنت بتمرن بس كنت بتمرن لوحدي
لانه كنت مش قادره ان انا اواجه حد وكنت
متضايقه جدا لما جيت ارجع بقى لقيت هو مين
قال لك ان انت اصلا في المنتخب تمام فانت
مش هتلعبي الاولمبيات وانت مش في منتخب
المهم حاولت ان انا بكل الطرق ان انا اصفي
او ان انا اصفي مع الناس اللي تم اختيارهم
عشان بال الاولمبيات بس ما كانش في فرصه
وفي زميله الانيه ربنا يعني وفقها ان هي
تسافر اي نعم انا ما وصلتش لحلمي وقعدت 12
سنه او اكتر يمكن بحاول اوصل لله بس انا
مش متضايقه بالعكس انا حاسه ان انا في
حاجات كتير قوي حققتها في الطريق لو ما
كنتش عندي الحلم ده عمري ما كنت احققها
يعني حققت 130 مداليا في بطولات
افريقيه
عربيه
بطولات كاس عالم بطولات عالم جبت مره خامس
عالم في 39 بلد وقدرت ان انا يختارون من
احسن 10 ديين في مصر ثلاث سنين ورا بعض و
من احسن انجازاتي الحمد لله كانت سنه 2013
لما اختاروني في تكريم هول اوف فين ده
يعتبر اعلى تكريم ممكن يحصل عليه اي رياضي
على مستوى العالم كنت اول بنت في افريقيا
والعرب اتكرم فيه ده كان ديسم
2013 وكان ليا تصنيف عالمي من الثالث
للخامس كذا سنه متتاليه ودي حاجه صعبه قوي
ان اي بنت عربيه تقدر ان هي توصل لها ا
وانا كنت بشتغل كمان الفتره دي يعني كنت
اتخرجت وبدات ان انا اشتغل ا المفاجاه بقى
اللي حصلت انا ما توقعتها خالص ا السنه دي
لقيت الاتحاد الدولي اختار 250 حكم على
مستوى العالم منهم 30 حكم من افريقيا عشان
يحكموا الاولمبيات
الجايه هو اناا لسه ما اختارنيش يعني دي
التصفيات الاولى يعني بس ان شاء الله ربنا
يسهل فكان في من ال 250 30 حكم افريقي
منهم خمس بنات فانا كنت في الخمس بنات دول
ف يعني كانت حاجه كويسه فدي كانت الشهر
اللي فات فنتمنى ان هي تكمل على خير ده
على المجال الرياضي كمان اهلي علموني ان
انا ما ينفعش ابقى مش يعني الرياضه مش مش
هتنفع من غير دراسه فكانت دايما بيشجعو ان
انا اكون متفوقه دراسيا اتخرجت من المدرسه
كنت الاولى على الدفعه نفس الكلام اتخرجت
هنا من الجامعه الامريكيه كنت برض من
الاوائل على الدفعه اتخرجت بمرتبه الشرف
والسنه دي خلصت ماجستير في اداره اعمال من
جامعه فيكتوريا في
سويسرا
[تصفيق]
وده كان متماشي مع شغلي وعملي التطوعي انا
بشتغل مديره موارد بشريه في شركه في مجال
السيارات شرف ليا ان انا اكون شغاله مع
ناس يعني اكبر مني
و وده يعتبر حاجه بالنسبه لي كوويسه قوي
ان انا بتعلم من كل الناس اللي حواليا
وكمان بشتغل في المجال التطوعي في جمعيه
اسمها حلم جمعيه دي لزوي
الاعاقه بتشجع على اندماج لزاويه الاعاقه
في جميع مجالات الحياه فانا بساعد في
الورش العمل اللي بتتعمل اللي بتدي
الاتكات بتاع التعامل مع كل نوع من انواع
الاعاقه وماسكه الجزء بتاع الموارد
البشريه اكتر حاجه في شغلي بحاول ان انا
اعملها ان مافيش اي حد يتظلم لان انا حسيت
بطعم الظلم وانا عارفه الظلم قد ايه بيوجع
فده اللي انا دايما بحاول في اي حاجه
بعملها ان انا احققه وعشان الحاجات اللي
انا يعني اعتقد انجزتها في المجال التطوعي
وفي مجال الرياضي اتكرمت من الامم المتحده
السنه اللي فاتت في جايزه
[تصفيق]
اسمها جايزه اسمها ومن اوف اتشيفمنت ودي
اختاروا 30 مراه على مستوى العالم يكرموه
عشان انجازاتهم تفوق العاده
يعني في منهم من بلاد مختلفه فانا كنت من
مصر طبعا كنت عايزه اشكر اهلي هم قاعدين
هنا
انا عمري ما كنت هحقق اي حاجه او اي خطوه
في حياتي من غير السبورت اللي هم ادوني
ومن غير ما هم يكونوا مصدقين فيا وكنت
عايزه اقول لكل حد ان مش لازم الواحد يعيش
في الصوره اللي المجتمع راسمها له او في
الطريق المجتمع راسمه له لازم يكون عنده
هدف لازم يحط هدف قدامه ولازم يسعى ان هو
يحقق الهدف
دوت ومش الفكره الهدف بس يعني الفكره
الرحله الوصول الى الهدف لان في النص
بيطلعلك حاجات كتير انت ممكن توصل لهدفك
تبقى مقصو بيه يوم اسبوع شهر والموضوع وقف
على كده بعين بتزهق بتبتدي تدور على حاجه
تانيه لكن المهم الرحله اللي ممكن تقعد
سنه اثنين لاثه وتتعلم فيها حاجات كتير
الكود دي بتعبر على اللي انا عايزه اقوله
ان الجمال جمال الرحله مش جمال المكان
اللي انا هوصله يعني ميرسي قوي
شكرا